Wow Wow 17 weeks whoa boiled down to one
pick show oh my gosh
except there's four more after this
somehow over Christmas Sims looks like
he lost another 10 to 15 pounds
somehow over Christmas I have gained
another 10 to 15 pounds and I have got a
few workouts in you you look so thin
where's the rest of you it's all here
all 230 of this Highway as same as I
always do the fact that you and I both
weigh 230 yes bearish dougie how was
your holiday it was good
oh it was good I think we're one or two
of what do you think 15 people in this
office today
I haven't even walked around to know
I've seen four people and that's it yes
got to keep doing it grow some of us got
to work around here somebody's gonna pay
the bills a bleacher report sales
teammate ah eat that sales how you like
that crap the pic spot yeah so cam
former producer came forward and
disputed what you said right I have
beaten you three times in the in the
official betting on Simms and left Cove
going through every game right this is
for the fourth year that we're going for
right now right and it is coming to an
absolute head because of the moves that
you made last week 7:30 on the Ravens
7:30 on the Steelers both cover Sims in
week 16 makes 1,500 out of a possible
$1600 incredible Adam how did I not make
more makes nothing five games ruse is
enough I don't understand you five games
wrong right you got I got two pushes you
got two pushes okay and so 14 60 plus 40
it came out to 1500 I made nothing and
lost nothing for what feels like the
eighth straight week I made zero this
past week right I lost nothing I made
zero the week before I made a hundred
the week before that I made zero like I
have been eight and eight seemingly for
the last four or five
amazing really where we at right now you
went ten four and two last week I went
six eight into not a good week for me
you are beating me by like six pics now
or four pics but I am beating you by
twelve hundred and ten dollars hard to
come back from so for the rule for the
regular season finale right you
obviously can catch you at the playoffs
you can still catch me in the regular
season if you do another big week and I
lose some money right you have a chance
yeah I got a chance gonna be tough gosh
what is this would you say the number
one 1210 damn it's almost no room for
error there it's goodness
it's gonna depend on really whether or
not you I don't really trust the whole
thing Josh can't do math and you don't
know let's go what do i dub i double
check because i challenge his math so
much josh is not here he's still in
Argentina right viva la Argentina
mountain biking and talking to me what
do you do this time of the year is it
coal it's in a cold there - the main
thing he told me is that he is not even
on his phone because there's no service
which is wild to think of Josh it is yes
but he's out doing adventures yeah cuz
it's like winter there isn't it I am NOT
up on wrong I swear I just saw something
in the Arctic I don't have my weather
boy to toss it - is there any news - the
Justin Herbert kid going back to Oregons
before we get into the pics um I mean I
do think it's I mean interesting I do
think from just my TV scouting through
the year he was clearly the number one
pick of the draft or the number one
quarterback really yeah for my money and
all the guys I saw and two or three guys
that you're even looking you know him
the kid from Duke of course the kid from
Ohio State I think the kid was from
Missouri you know they didn't have as
good a year as a team so hey the team
wasn't good so he must of course you
know but those are the kid will Grier
from West Virginia right those are all
the main names but yes he was the one
that jumped out to me the most I mean to
me he's making a mistake
the way I can say why ever come back
exactly right why ever come back you
hear someone have left after his junior
year yeah and you stayed for your senior
I stayed yeah but not because I wanted
to I mean if I had a good big 12
championship game I would have been like
peace out I'm done yeah right so that
changed things
dramatically for
me but yeah you only get one chance at
it that's where I live got picked up
being the top quarterback picked you
never know injury-wise what can happen
you can have a bad year and your team
you could have a good year and your team
do bad and everybody goes but we're not
a first for me what about I'm not ready
yeah I still need to work on my craft I
don't think I'm ready to make like if
you if you look at that point yes but
everything I read just at least quote
wise was just he wanted to go back to
college for a year and it for me I
understand that and I like I'm never
gonna tell us some kid what to do with
their life but I also I don't yeah I
don't think it's the right decision
long-term I don't I think you're risking
a whole lot the risk is not worth the
reward or the reward is not worth
whatever when you hear someone say well
I made a promise to my parents that I'm
gonna get a degree yes I know it's the
school will be there for years and years
to come
in fact I'm just gonna say that I
probably could take it online probably
could do a lot of different if your
career goes great look you're not gonna
have a lot to do afterwards right you
can go back to college I don't know but
I just I agree with you there's a window
to be the topic and the draft and the
reaction by everybody was oh he was
gonna be the topic right you know I mean
um Matt Barkley everybody told me he was
gonna be the number one pick went back
to calm went back to college team didn't
do well all sudden he struggled [ __ ] he
went in the mid rounds you don't mean
and it's not even about that necessarily
because I think that the people who
didn't count in evaluations were
evaluating Matt Barkley to make those
comments like we've talked about it a
lot like SportsCenter anchors you're
calling him the number one pick right um
and they have no clue but the qualifying
yeah they're qualifying but the the
thing you also that you and I talked
about a lot would like those top picks a
lot of the times is the amount of also
the amount of chances you get when
you're a top ten pick they do everything
they can to make sure it works your
career is extended like four more sub
teams is bar Barkevious Mingo been on
how many teams will blame gap exactly
right see what I mean so when you're top
ten everyone kicks the tires on you
because they go we had a top good draft
grade on there must be something there
maybe we can get out of them get it out
of them and as we always say goes to the
coach's ego I'll be the one exactly
right it's all part of it - exactly but
you know what and I want to say not mad
at them I got it
I don't want to minimize getting a
degree right exactly a great thing to
have and it's super valuable in the law
but at the same time you know life is
about opportunity right and an athlete's
opportunities are fleeting exactly the
reason we support levy on bail sitting
out stay out get your money that's right
um the last thing I want to say before
we get to the Pyxis yeah I'm going that
to the mall later are you are you gonna
fill ruruta
have you seen bird box yet uh no what is
this show on Netflix that people are
talking about it look you can't look at
something because if you see it it's
gonna make you commit suicide it's a
very dressed oh my gosh I'm really sold
spider hair but yeah here's what I'm
realizing at week 17 it's madness yeah
we have no idea who's playing we have no
idea if they're gonna be giving effort
I'm an Eagles fan I'm preying on the
Bears to play their starters to beat the
Vikings I at the same point right on the
Bears why would I bring out good plays
and my starters again so I could play
them it's it's weirds madness it is just
like burr box I'm gonna bird box you
yeah in bird box the people that
survived blind right because they
couldn't see I can't see I have no idea
anyway so in essence I have a better
chance than you because you know what
should happen and that ain't gonna
happen
I don't know so in the world of bird box
there behind our supreme I am gonna win
this because I have no idea it is a
weird week if it's one of the weirdest
weeks figuring out the money and doing
that yet playing all the angles you're
talking about is this team gonna play
their motivation my only thing is is
like what what do you do if you're the
Bears like seriously let's just have
that combo right now like what do you do
what do you what would you be you're and
you're just the Bears right block out
Eagles and all that you're just you're
there you're the Bears you're the head
coach in the GM well I will say this I
am forever changed after what I saw by
the Rams this season okay and the impact
of resting people right I believe that
if you're a team like the Bears who
every week just goes out there and beats
the crap out of people yeah does he
haven't had injuries all year that
continue did you continue the crap out
of people yeah like I'm with you I think
if I was like not playing for 16 minutes
is that
really the rest that I need to go out
there and steamroll through the plasto
dude just keep doing it yeah like I saw
what happened to the Rams they sat for a
week and then dud dud dud and they're
still trying to come that they are I
know and you last year they do the same
thing in this place I mean they did a
Sat week 17 remember they laid a dud in
the wild-card game against the Falcons
so yeah I know it's really odd to not
resting anymore we don't believe in it
I'm with you you have to be careful so
us the 46 players right this is not
college there's not 90 yeah it's 46 yeah
so I don't really want good players out
there with bad players I get you you
know cuz I don't want that guy to miss a
block that's usually blocked and all of
a sudden my guards knees are out because
I don't have enough depth there the
bears one is fascinating it's
fascinating to me too because you go
okay gee so do you put all your eggs in
the let's win this week basket right
okay you do that let's win this week get
them out so we don't have to play them
third the third time you play but then
you also have to worry about the Eagles
and also but you also have to worry
about is you put all your eggs in there
let's win this one this basket and we
don't win yeah but you know is that due
to the psyche of your team to my number
one thing that I would say to you yeah
is the most annoying thing to hear from
coaches and athletes is always one game
at a time
mm-hmm if you're gonna preach that all
the time yeah and then when the playoffs
come around go one game at a time
except that other game no dude it's all
you've talked to me yeah I just want to
keep winning yes I know but it's it's
not always like that
oh just chicken out they're gonna worry
about injuries as Matt Nagy said if I'm
up 21 or something crazy then I'll start
there yeah I agree with that all right
the first game it's my season-long bet
oh it is and I have no idea what your
picks are Miami at Buffalo yeah Miami is
a three and a half point underdog Sims
take it away okay that was weird
we're used to Josh I'm not used to it by
the way the weather around kickoff is
supposed to be 32 degrees with nine mile
per winds out of the south and we could
just sum it up like this it'll be cold
and it's not Miami weather that's the
problem
okay I mean what do we take your the
dolphins it seems like Adam GaSe has
survived right he's going to make it it
sounds like Tannenbaum is going to be
out I will say this I didn't realize
gates had full control of their roster
so it's not which I found out well all
those Pouncy moves yes roll him I get
that yes and you know hey one of the
issues with their team is depth in
general and of course quality across the
board but I did not realize that until
this past weekend but either way you
know in Buffalo you and I have talked
about this a million times Buffalo is a
different team up there it's a tough
place to go up to anyways especially
when you have no motivation
I think the bills are a little bit you
know again well coached tough football
team cousin McDermott yeah I think Josh
Allen they're all trying to build
something for the future a lot like some
of these other teams with young
quarterbacks and things like that
I got nothing no feel for this overall
other than that I just feel like the
bills are there a better quality team
when they're at home and I don't trust
the Dolphins and what they can do we saw
the Dolphins they struggle against good
defenses just like last week against
Jacksonville
so I'm oddly enough putting $10 on the
Dolphins left go oh but be careful a
little dolphin
it's very cold water up there and it's
it's the lake and it's the freaking
waterfall what's that called
Niagara Falls it's not salty salty water
of dolphin be careful up there okay but
I am it's ok dolphin it's ok it's ok
it's just one game but the bills I'm
going to pick to win the game 19 to 16
so that point five is why I'm going ten
on the Dolphins 19 to 6 I attained 216
the story of the Miami wants to move on
from Tannehill and 2019 that came out is
very interesting Adam GaSe has been
getting in trouble this week for sitting
in the bench sitting on the bench story
in the Jaguar which is just ludicrous
I mean we celebrated Sean McVeigh for
sitting on the bench and coming up with
plays yeah and now we look at him Gason
everyone just down in Miami is
questioning Adam GaSe yeah we I came up
with four all of these except really to
the end I'm gonna need your help how
we're gonna remember the 2018 season for
all the
teams yeah so the 2018 Miami Dolphins
for me is unfinished business I still
have questions about Tannehill I still
have questions about gays I still have
questions about that entire team I know
nothing about that roster I have
questions about Kenyan Drake and like is
he the guy like why does he only touch
the ball like Devante Parker are you
gonna cut him like nothing about the
Dolphins feel set in stone everything
feels up in the air yeah
the Buffalo Bills my thing for them the
2018 Buffalo Bills the bounce-back yeah
what everything when they hit the bottom
starts to bounce back I believe that
Buffalo hit their bottom in the
beginning of this season with Nathan
Peterman this has been two or three
years coming guys getting older losing
people they hit the bottom and now
they're bouncing back up and Josh Allen
is the guy that's gonna make it happen
but don't forget I have two season-long
bets in this game mm-hmm that the
Buffalo Bills will lose like will only
win five games right and the Dolphins
will win more than seven right so I am
putting out $50 on Miami uh because you
want it to happen I need it to happen
yeah it's the it's really the one like
the weird game at one o'clock that I'm
gonna care about yeah I can't believe
I'm invested it's crazy
that really is and it'd be interesting
to see can you believe they're gonna
move on from Tannehill though I don't
believe that yet no I don't because I I
think listen I understand there's
concerns case has the power with
tannenbaum leaving I do not think that
at Teddy Hill will be gone I don't
either
well I think could also get him at a
very affordable price I think the first
thing would tannenhill is just like okay
yeah I know he's not like top five
quarterback material but who are you
gonna get that's better see he's stuck
in that middle-of-the-road category
where we're always gonna go man we could
do a little bit better but I'm gonna go
Dan but I could show you worse till I
could show you a whole lot worse as we
crack down the the numbers of the NFL at
the quarterback position and we start to
go okay yeah you want to go down towards
the bottom of the list of some of these
sorry teams and see their quarterback
situation now I think cases in on
Tannehill III will be shocked if that's
the that's the case in my head yeah
Buffalo wins this game yes I would I
would be shocked
Giambi's one push it I really would just
be the worst the bills if you had to
give me some up the season the build
their building something there right now
that's what I really like to build I
mean I really am excited about their
style of football and Josh Allen and the
Dolphins yeah well how would you sum up
the 2018 I want to be like same old
questions it's just like you beat the
teams you were supposed to be yeah but
you never really beat any of the any you
know just I don't know what I want to
say would that map I still have a lot of
the same questions I feel like I've had
the last few years finish yes they're
just there's there's holes in that
roster that need to be improved
I stole unfinished business last night
me and my girlfriend were just like
laying down and I was like looking
through HBO and the best man you ever
seen that movie sure Morris Chestnut
Taye Diggs all these guys right and he
writes a book called unfinished business
right and there's a part where Morris
Chestnut is an NFL player and he plays
on the Giants and they're going the
playoffs he just got a big contract I
don't remember a favor said his position
yeah but at one point the woman that he
ends up marrying looks at him and she
goes to be honest the advice I'd give
you is to stop playing on turf it's
gonna limit your career by 60% and I was
like I watched this random 90s movie and
even they are grass not to yes right
alright Detroit at Green Bay Green Bay
is favored by eight and if we go to the
weather it's expected to be in the 30s
with 16 mile-per-hour winds
right Green Bay favored by 8 at home ok
so yeah at home you know another game
that it's harder team what do they play
it's hard to get a feel for I think the
Lions are gonna be playing for a little
more something than people are getting
the credit format Patricia I think is
finally you know kind of got the vote of
confidence that he will be back he's
gonna want to end the year on a strong
note I do think to the thing that always
scares me in this type of matchup is you
know the same thing that always scares
me about Green Bay in general their
offense is very simple and guys like
Matt Patricia know the offense as good
as the Joe Philbin does on the sidelines
ok it's he might as well just be there
next to him ago you got you like that
one Joe alright don't worry we'll be all
over it so it puts a lot of pressure on
Rodgers through that situation and you
know again I think that Matt's staff I
think that the
they're gonna be semi motivators what
I'm saying I've been nothing to Packers
I think the Packers will be as well I
don't know if they're going to be eight
points favorite motivated that to me is
a little much okay did feel like a lot I
feel like that was a high number for a
team that like just doesn't blow teams
out in general like maybe we're down to
the Jets by of thirteen but Green Bay at
home is a different animal I get that I
do and I don't think the Lions are you
know as wussy as years past either okay
so I'm going $10 on the Lions mm-hmm I
think it's just too much eight points I
don't think the Lions are gonna like ah
I don't think they're just gonna fold
10th I guess is what I'm saying I think
that they're gonna at least put up a
good defensive effort and Matt Stafford
he's gonna want to try to finish the
year somewhat positively because he's
been crapped on and hasn't played about
the whole year
look the true thing is so the Packers
this year are 5-1 and one at Lambeau
against the spread oh no no excuse me
that's just straight up but four and
three against the spread the Lions
though five and two against the spread
on the road I'm just gonna give you some
of this as a background and the Lions
have actually done pretty well against
against Green Bay they've won three
straight against the Packers so if you
look at that it's pretty good
lock of the week Matt Patricia the story
comes out constantly late to his own
meetings like that's as much [ __ ] as
Adam GaSe sitting on the sidelines the
head coach is allowed to be late for his
meetings there are his meetings first of
all okay and it's not like he's sitting
there sitting there going like hold on
team I got to finish my bowl of cereal
or hold on guys I'm watching I'm
watching BR live hold on a second let me
that's what he's doing he's going to
hold on everybody hold on no lon I'm
almost done my doughnuts almost done it
seemed like the story was more of a note
right as he was thirty minutes he pushed
a press conference with the media back
30 and was 15 minutes late to that yeah
and then that spurred a former player
coming out and saying he was late all
the time yeah well I mean listen I don't
know too many head coaches that were on
time for their morning team meeting cuz
there's always something balichek
Belichick yeah for the most part but I
think there's a lot of meat morning
meetings there where it was okay we're
supposed to meet at 8:30 and he didn't
walk into a 36 or 837 room definitely
because there josh mcdaniels yes I have
Fisher definitely yes so this is the
second time that Patricia is being
derided by the media right actually
really the third time first time would
be when he came after the reporter for
slouches right second time was when he
was practicing outdoors right and said
it meant something they didn't yeah and
there's probably even more but now he's
late to his own meet right
yeah there's no such thing when the head
coach is the you know he he's not late
he's not like like oh I'm so unorganized
oh damn we got a meeting in five minutes
oh my gosh I'm not ready no it's because
somebody he's had to talk to some player
or the GM came down and all of a sudden
is like hey they want to trade or do
this so he's talking about something but
you know that's where it's like the gay
story it's just that's a bunch of BS
that's habeas is why I love trying to
because because it's so normal to go wow
he's late he's unorganized he's not
buttoned up look at the way he dressed
exactly look at his beard I like Bella
check was yeah and it's it's it's just
funny to step back and go no most head
coaches are late because they're head
coaches and there have a million things
to deal with like when they walk down
the hallway a head coach is literally
young like people pulling them
everywhere Jeff Bezos was late yeah
exactly
there you go Green Bay interviewed Chuck
Pagano and Jim Caldwell yes what do you
think about those two I mean two of the
most underrated coaches we've had the
last few years I don't think it's the
right fit for Green Bay and Aaron
Rodgers totally but I think those are
two guys that deserve another hit at
some point while I Drive agree with you
with Pagano really because I believe
that too many other people have had
success with his core when he did not
have that success right Bruce Arians had
sand look because everything went
through Bruce Arians and then what Frank
Wright is doing compared to when but
like it just wasn't the same
the Colts as I mentioned last year we're
ahead going into the fourth quarter and
nine of their 16 games sure and blue
no one's blown that as in much as
history as Pagano did last year yeah I
guess so that's my issue cold while I
agree with you right the amount of times
he took them to the playoffs the the the
discipline that that team had and I
think that Jim Bob cooter has been an
issue that no one's talked about sure
and I think Caldwell had that
in a very good spot it was unfair yeah
Pagano I believe that there were
failings that's how I feel yeah I'm my
only thing I would push back with you is
the roster was crappy okay he didn't
have this offensive line he had this
year did your luck last year so that's
kind of hairy right and I only think I
would say too is when those teams are
crappy early on in his things they over
performed I mean he went 11 he went to
the playoffs three straight years they
lead it off and I know Bruce Arians took
over that one year when he was hurt or
sick Gotham's downfalls that he's too
fun in the media these things and does
stuff and he's likable exactly right I
and I get you there but yeah I just feel
like they've been underappreciated both
of them I'm gonna give my some ups of
the season yeah I'll let you think about
it and then give my bet Detroit the 2018
Detroit Lions the slouching reporter
that's just how I'm always gonna
remember Detroit it's it's they're
they're kind of loose they come out with
a bang and they're not they're just kind
of a lazy reporter right Green Bay the
2018 Green Bay Packers the break-up
it was the end yeah it was the end of
Mike McCarthy it was the end of Aaron
Rodgers and now they each have to go a
succeed on their own right whether it's
Mike McCarthy in Arizona
or Aaron Rodgers to somebody else we
will now see how they stand on their own
two feet I agree with you eight points
as too much and I am putting 50 dollars
on the Detroit Lions gadget so what I'm
really doing here is I'm just bringing
up the news that's being talked about
because breaking down the game I have no
idea what these teams are playing yeah
it's okay you're right there's no
there's nothing to break down this game
for there's gonna be young kids in the
game there's maybe a lot of things that
and we will not be talking about the
Packers the Lions the bills are the
Dolphins really in the next few weeks
right well this is our chance to talk
about that's our chance yeah
Jacksonville at Houston Houston at home
favored by seven they can still possibly
steal the number-2 seat away from the
Patriots if the Patriots lose to the
Jets and they beat the Jaguars other
than that it looks like they can still
be the 1 seed if the Chiefs and the
Patriots lose yes they can
well the Chargers too they can be the 1
seed I believe and I believe they can be
the 6 seed all the same weekend not
amazing they are taking on Blake bortles
in his return because he turns Houston
by seven what do you think
um you know Houston of course is the
better football team we got that I have
the same concerns about Houston you've
heard me talk about all year long I mean
Houston when they have to play a team
that has a good defense it concerns me
uh because they kind of do feast on the
poor you've heard my concerns about
their past game right and how there's
not enough schemes there and the
different things to do creatively in a
weekly basis you know they try to run
the ball but they only run the ball on
the poor like we've talked about a bar
should be back right Tamara is Thomas
out for the year yeah yep so those are
you know things that concern me about
the matchup Blake bortles coming back on
the other side concerns me a little bit
as well cuz he can run well he can run
exactly right and at least there is some
familiarity there with things they want
to do on the offensive side of the ball
and there's somewhat of a formula of a
winning style of football so you believe
ya bake Blake bortles playing
quarterback for the Jaguars gives them a
better chance to make it tough on the
Texans I just wanted to like say it
again say it again yes as compared to
Cody Kessler yes yes yeah I I do I think
they match up with the Texans to where
again I'm gonna sit here and go I'm
puttin ten dollars on the Texans and I'm
gonna pick the Texans to win this game
24 213 but I also wouldn't be shocked as
this game was 17 to 13 that's why I
can't go hard on it like I've told you
I'd you know Jacksonville I don't think
their defense is gonna fall asleep at
the wheel this week and I think Blake
bortles and the offense are gonna try to
show a little something in this game I
don't think they're totally going to
just abandon ship and quit on the year
I'm just gonna get my pick first
I have $50 in the Houston Texans minus
seven as well it's I just I Houston at
home yeah makes gives me a lot more
confidence
fernette might not play Yeah right the
jaguars for me it's like I feel like
they may have given their last-ditch
effort last week I think good over Miami
cutter and I think Houston has a lot to
play for the summary of the Jacksonville
seat the summary of the Houston season
for me is the formula 2018 Houston
Texans the formula works and the formula
is
a strong front for with a cluster of
defensive players in the back with a
little bit of weapons and a quarterback
that you can't game plan for right there
are the 2017 Philadelphia Eagles without
as good of an offensive game plan but
with maybe a more athletic quarterback
and a better front 7 sure that's the
formula sure it's what we saw work last
year I think they're running the same
formula yeah my Jacksonville 2018 the
2018 Jacksonville Jaguars the truth
hurts hmm the truth hurts I like that
one it's a good one it's you look around
and you go you knew it all along and you
thought you could keep rolling the dice
yeah it's gonna come up snake eyes once
or twice that's right
and to think that you can trot out the
same thing every year the the misnomer
about the Patriots is that it's been the
Patriots for eighteen years the Patriots
are a different team every year yeah
right the Patriots that we have this
year are different team guys alone than
what we saw last we haven't seen this
Patriots team till 2000 2003
yes 15 years this is a fact this is back
to Tom Brady being carried by well not
being a carry but Corey Dillon yeah
boundless football yeah you're right no
I know I know you're right they thought
they were gonna be able to Jacksonville
Jaguars gonna go we are P feds can just
dominate once again and they'll score a
touchdown every game and teams will
struggle it ain't broke don't exactly
and realize that in the NFL yeah
everybody gets broke you ain't better
you getting worse exactly how would did
you would you like to sum them up at any
other way um
the Jags would be like a wasted year
who's what I would say something along
that and the Texans I don't know how I
would sum it up I would almost want to
say way to go left go yeah yeah way to
go but something along the lines of like
this was a big building block season
you're gonna get to go into the playoffs
with deshaun Watson and have a chance
and no matter what happens from here on
out the year was a positive yes and
they're a team to watch out for in the
futures they remind me of a little bit
of the Eagles last season I don't know
if they're gonna the postseason success
they remind me a lot of that one Derek
Carr Raiders year yeah where
like the scheduled condom was friendly
and everything clicked at the same time
but they still have their quarterback
but can they do it in the postseason
unfortunately for that Raiders team they
lost Eric Carr right my question for the
Texans going forward will be will they
build on this going into the future or
was this just a one-year where it all
clicked no we'll see I think there's
something built in there I hope so I do
all right let's now move on to the Jets
at the Patriots the Patriots are favored
by 13 and a half hmm can the Patriots
get the 1 seed or no no I don't believe
the Patriots they might be able to fill
a keeps lose that's your job you're the
host you don't know that it's wrong with
you but either way they're still playing
for a buy right and the Jets I don't
think they can get the 1 seed I might be
wrong but I'm gonna look that up real
quick the weather at one o'clock 32
degrees 5 miles per hour wind it 5 miles
per hour wind a very dry day right at
Gillette Stadium are you typing in can
the Patriots get the 1 seed yeah I'm
trying to look now dammit
sorry guys are you doing it yeah
Patriots can get the 1 CASC it's
officially the last week of the regular
season but no seats have been set ok
yeah so they need to just need the
Chiefs and chargers to lose basically I
guess right yeah thirteen and a half
Sims okay um hey with the Patriots I
think the big thing is here you know of
course the offense has had issues lately
it's been inconsistent I do think that
they're going to try to go into the
playoffs on a very positive note they're
certainly gonna be no falling asleep at
the wheel this week whether it be
players or game plan wise I kind of feel
the same way about the Jets too though I
don't think the Jets are going to just
like quit on the year either again they
have a young rookie quarterback who's
played well the last two weeks I think
there you are building on something with
him for the future I think your
offensive coordinator and those guys
they're fighting for their career so
they want to have a good game because
they're hoping that they can show enough
to where whoever takes over and head
coach for Todd Bowles he might want to
keep them Todd Bowles I think soon still
want to end up on a dick big you know on
a positive note as well you know hoping
that there might be a chance he stays on
but I don't think that's happening just
so everybody
okay so the big thing is I'm betting $10
on the Jets here hmm I know it's just a
year where I can't pick the Patriots in
this type of game most years I feel like
Oh thirteen and a half there's trying to
make us chicken out and picking them and
they're really gonna win 31 to 39 those
lions always make you think yeah I just
don't feel that way with the Pats this
year and I do think the Jets with darn
old and some of the things they do on
the defensive side of the ball can be a
pain in the butt for the Patriots so the
Patriots win the game but I'm only gonna
say 28 to 20 I don't think they're going
to run away with this I think there's
enough there to keep the Jets motivated
um
Tremayne Johnson was held oh I'll go do
my pick first yeah I'm just gonna say
this ahead of time almost all of these
games with the huge lines cuz there's
about four or five I'm pretty much going
the underdog yeah because I'm watching
the shop which is on HBO and it's LeBron
and he's sitting around there with
icecube and Chris Bosh and Todd Gurley
and Jimmy Kimmel were the ones I
remember offhand in the first session
before mary j blige and anna-lena got on
there but todd gurley they said why is
it always close why can it go last to
first and all that he goes it's you
don't blow teams out in the NFL yeah
everybody's close I look at the Patriots
that game last week in which they went
and didn't cover the spread against
Buffalo
if Julian Edelman doesn't roll over
somebody's back and go for a touchdown
that's a one-possession game late it
required like an all-time highlight to
even get to that point Buffalo was in
the game the entire time
Sam Darnell has played adequately lately
he's making the necessary throws he's
running around he's making good plays
and you know what they've been playing
for bowls they were up 15 over the
Packers at home the Jets have covered
three of the last four times they've
played the Patriots and the Patriots are
not a team built right now to just blow
people out willy-nilly no no what they
are I just and I also could see you know
pulling some guys late right Tom Brady
got pulled last week with six minutes
left well a thirteen and a half point
spread against a team that's one to play
I to will put $50 on the New York
um yeah I just don't see it Tremayne
Johnson being held out of Wednesday
practice called an in-house matter
anything there I don't know
I know his play hasn't been up to par
for what they're paying him I don't know
anything behind the scenes to let you
know there but yeah I I don't I know
that they have to be somewhat
disappointed but the way he's played I
mean they're paying him to be a shutdown
corner and he's had too many moments
this year where people have had big
plays or just attacked him in general
like you heard me say maybe five or six
weeks ago to me it looks like he lost
the gear this year that was my big thing
as the gear went on I just went damn
when people ran by him who was never
gaining any ground or he never stayed
with the fast receivers he was almost a
liability when it came to deep routes
down the field if he didn't get a good
Jam in you on the line of scrimmage so
I'm sure they're not happy with them is
there a chance right that because of the
way the Rams were last year playing
ahead all of the the entire season I
know you thought he's been good for
really long yeah yeah but getting a
little bit more of a predictive opponent
play sure could that have inflated them
maybe a little bit before now go to the
Jets where people will take shots on you
at any time and you have no idea what's
coming because you're either playing
you're playing from behind or you're
playing it even yeah it's it's a
different game and I think more than
anything is what happens is he's a guy
that was on the franchise tag for two
years in a row and he stayed tip-top
shape and ready to play and he finally
got his big payday this year in New York
he just didn't quite you know dot his
eyes and cross his T's all the way to
start to start the season the 2018 New
York Jets come back Sam and what I mean
by that is from the first game of the
year throws a pick six to Detroit and
then roars back at the end and instills
confidence right to the middle of this
season when he played awful against
Miami right and then everyone was
challenging him and he was hurt for five
weeks and the way he's played the last
few weeks Sam is showing he's got the
grit he's got the gut and this is the
future of the team yeah and he's gonna
come back and I have a lot of faith in
him going forward New England Patriots
the 2018 New England Patriots Belichick
does it again somehow mm-hmm Belichick
should be coach of the year and we can
say it every single year
Gronk has faded the defense really does
not have that much talent when you look
around it's a lot of pieces that are
somehow cobbled together and he could
somehow still get the first place in the
AFC and it's it's it's not when Tom
Brady comes to town it's when Bill
Belichick comes to town it's amazing
it's amazing it is I just want to take
this time to honor him because holy crap
it's special Sims yeah it is there's
nothing like it he's the greatest coach
in the history of the sport it's not
even close and yeah I mean all the
points you made or truly firm to me New
England I would say Lynne has more
talent Matt Nagy has more talent
definitely Carroll now that's the only
thing I would argue with those as bill
has this is his talent there's no
denying that he's the one that built the
team so right there's talent issues it's
cuz of him okay good point but he's not
winning GM of he's not winning GM of the
year but he's still finding the formula
that works for what he's doing and he
doesn't believe in being top-heavy and I
didn't mean to dispel your thing you're
saying that that's a great point but the
beginning of the end that's what I look
at it as new I think it's the beginning
of the end you know not the end not the
end but it's the first time we've seen
you know just little cracks and the
seams to go okay yep they're going to
have to it's about that time where we're
seeing Brady start to go downhill and
yes they're still really good but it's
the first time we're seeing it go that
way I think in the last of 2018 New York
Jets
yeah the 28th New York Jets I want to be
like you know something of building wise
building something or found your
franchise something like that along that
as far as your sit back I do yes they
got their guy I like Sam a whole lot
yeah do I think he's got the highest
potential of like a baker or Josh Allen
no but I think he is a franchise
starting quarterback for a long long
time for that football team we better
hurry we're doing okay okay we good I'm
just letting you know we've only gone
through four games and okay let's go
fast right Carolina New Orleans New
Orleans favored by nine yeah yeah I mean
again it's teddy bridgewater show don't
know really what the Saints are going to
do or what to expect from them you know
I think they're gonna run their offense
I just don't know
who's gonna be in and out of the game
what Lyman did they keep safe whatever
that may be and then Carolina hey I mean
what sort of said do I think their
defense is going to give a spirited
effort sure the quarterback situation is
a little Lyle Allen is making us write
his first career start and he'll be
throwing he's only thrown four throws
yeah I mean they were all last week
weren't they yes
yeah I mean and he's the Texas A&M kid
who transferred and I can't remember
where he transferred from at one point
but at the end of the day I mean come on
I'm going with the Saints okay I'm
putting ten dollars on this yeah I just
still think the Saints will have
offensive line a decent scheme going in
the game their defense is still sound
I'm gonna say they win the game like 23
to 13 because the Panthers just can't
muster up any offense Kyle Allen is
still walking to the sidelines to get
signals and doesn't realize yet that
there's a microphone that's hilarious
Teddy Bridgewater is gonna play and you
know what yeah cuz of that I'm gonna
blow your mind I'm going 350 dollars on
the Saints okay big time right why
because you've always said this and I'm
using your information yeah the Saints
could still go to the Super Bowl with
Teddy Bridgewater Sean Payton is not
taking the foot off the gas I'm getting
an angry defense that almost got beat by
the Steelers last week against Kyle
Allen Kyle Allen that's incredible
Teddy Bridgewater is gonna run it fine
and the number one thing to everybody
there's 46 men on an active roster when
you're a team like the Saints and you
have good depth those guys are still
gonna play yeah you know yes it's still
gonna be they are still gonna get it
flowing
I think the Saints go out there and
absolutely bash them and Teddy
Bridgewater Teddy Bridgewater is this
team I don't know if you've seen it on
social media he does the chopper dance
and he's the one leading the dances in
the Saints locker room yeah he's gonna
go out there ready to put up buckets
right and the team's gonna go let's ball
out for Bridgewater you're not the
future of our team
that's Taysom Hill but an amazing season
we want to ball out I think they destroy
the Panthers okay
and this was the game that they the
almost lost to them two weeks ago yeah
they're motivated to kick that ass
you're not buying it well I don't know
what to buy but this game I feel really
calm yeah it's fine I don't think it's a
core I don't think you're crazy at all I
just there's a little too many unknowns
for my thought of all the teams that
were Feria of all the teams that were
favored by 14 and a half right when I
saw the Saints were only favored by nine
it blew me away
right it blew me away yeah the Saints
kicked the app and kicked about Panthers
ass last time they played in the second
half I think that continues anyway
yeah the 2018 Carolina Panthers I call
it the crying shoulder why you have been
putting this franchise on the shoulders
of Cam Newton for years and you know
what it finally came crashing down and
it's not Cam's fault it's not as body's
fault you've asked him to do too much
and the one year it just it came
crashing down right the New Orleans
Saints the 2018 New Orleans Saints I
call it the perfect marriage
drew Brees and Sean Payton are opposites
drew Brees literally can do no wrong
Sean Payton if given his druthers could
go out there and be the party starter
but together they are the perfect
marriage and this was the year that it
all clicked this is the year that the
line was right the weapons were right
the time was right and Drew Brees as
play was right and it all came together
and they fulfilled your prophecy it's
the perfect marriage yeah that's how I
felt about their two seasons yeah it's
the championship run that's what the
Saints are doing right now that's how I
would be that's how I would kind of
clarify it yes
they've been a team that's you know
building to this point and and they were
there and yes if you made me pick right
now the Saints are going to win the
Superbowl the Carolina Panthers I think
I would go like something like missed
opportunity missed opportunity where
they were sitting there six and two and
blew a number of games where they
controlled the tempo of those games
where they you know you talked about
that one losing stretch there where they
got blown out by the Steelers but
certainly could have beat the Lions that
was a wide-open two-point conversion
Seahawks dominated the football game and
screwed it up the Buccaneers game the
week before the next week that was cam
throwing some dumb interceptions
a few dumb things they had the Browns
lost where they had a chance to win of
course the Saints game that you
mentioned so you know I just look at it
from the NFC perspective - with a team
like this you know they could have been
a team that could have been dangerous
you know I if they kind of fulfilled
what they totally were but they but they
did not the other name for Carolina
season screw Thursday Night Football
yeah right because that depends per game
changed everything did you look at the
clock no okay good
I was worried all right Dallas at the
Giants right
Giants favored by six right and I'm
looking at the weather right now no
Odell it doesn't look like 34 degree 35
degrees at kickoff right five
mile-per-hour winds
okay I think the Giants are clearly
gonna be the more motivated team in this
game it could be Eli Manning's last game
we don't know that I think you're gonna
a decent little fan base there so
there'll be that aspect of it altogether
I don't think the Cowboys are going to
you know rest their team completely but
certainly not gonna be Zeke has come out
and I want to play to get the rusher
yeah I know I mean that sounds great but
I don't think they're gonna be giving it
to them like in the fourth quarter like
sludge it up the middle one more time
Zeke to get the record you know so those
are the things I look at I do think that
the the Cowboys will keep it close to a
degree but at the end of the day I am
picking the Giants wow I am I'm gonna go
with Giants I'm going $10 on the Giants
Tim I there's part of me that wants you
to load up on one game I'm going to go
ten dollars in the gym yeah I'm gonna
say 24 213 yeah I don't think the
Cowboys are gonna do much schematically
on either side of the ball and I think
because of the Eloi factor and it's the
Cowboys the Giants will put up one more
big spirited effort and don't you worry
I am going one big game I'm taking you
to places you've never seen before I
looked at this yeah and I went the
Giants by six yeah I'm putting $100 in
the Cowboys our first disagreement
I don't know if it's our first it is I'm
all the games and smarts the first one
we've disagreed on yeah
I I look at this game and I go maybe
Giants by three but if you believe that
the Giants are that much more like
they're gonna care that much more about
against the Dallas Cowboys yeah
the Dallas defense is super deep sure
like I think Eli's gonna struggle where
to the Giants struggle at home it's a
lot of things on Eli's mind he's gonna
want to play great like I don't know I
look at the Dallas game and unless I get
four quarters of Cooper Rush and he just
stinks I like Dallas is basic anyway you
know like I think Michael Gallup can do
stuff on these guys if Amari Cooper sits
i I just the giants favored by six is
wild to me look you think they're gonna
care that much more well when I see of
games like this I see that and I go wow
you guys really do think that caring
more is what matters in the NFL well and
these type of games I I do think it will
to a degree I do I think one team's
going
we're already checked out to the next
week and we could talk about it all we
want and nothing they're just gonna
totally lay down but I do think the
Giants are also first-year head coach
he's trying to build something into the
future Eli issue yeah I when I picked
them to win these type of games to let
go I don't envision it being like it was
24 nothing Giants you know I think it's
gonna be like you know 14 13 Giants and
then 17 13 Giants and then Timmy knows
the Tabasco super bad for the Cowboys
comes in and he fumbles or with that
that's how I look at it so uh my well I
got our route for the Panthers and the
Giants yeah that's easy for you the new
year the 2018 New York Giants the big -
the big - yeah sake wanna know down and
you know what we live in a world where
you need big threes and I call it the
big - cuz you ain't got the third yeah
you don't have the quarterback right and
you're probably not gonna have the
quarterback again next year the this
this year for the Giants is gonna be it
really should be purgatory you're not
bad you're not good you're just in the
middle because you haven't made a
decision yet
right you're waiting right and and
you're waiting is getting you nowhere
it's all on the side yeah the Dallas
Cowboys 2018 another other year and what
I buy that is every other Cowboys are
every other year and this was another
other year yeah where last year their
offensive line was hurt Zeke was
suspended whatever and they won like six
or seven games the year before that
their offensive line was healthy and
Zeke was there and they won 13 games the
year before that their offensive line
was hurt and they didn't have any
offense and they were bad the year
before that their offensive line was
great they made it work they had a run
the Cowboys do it every year
next year I'm betting against him just
gonna tell you it's every other year so
this was another other year yeah yeah
Cowboys are they're dangerous man I
don't ride waves I wish I you would have
told me this before we started the show
so I could have something a little more
I need to bring something individual and
unique okay you bring ball knowledge I
bring summing up things in movie titles
no reason the year of Eli the book of
evil what will they do Atlanta at Tampa
Bay yeah Tampa Bay favored by one and in
Tampa Oh to live in Tampa it will be 79
degrees 71% humidity feels good gosh I
got you back where I used to be walking
down Bayshore Boulevard in Tampa living
the good life riding jet skis doing all
that good stuff seeing dolphins go
underneath me man
Danielle my wife is doing that really
yes but at the end I got some jet skis
when I was living down there that was
awesome be going through the bay you
know like when you own a jet ski how
often do you jet ski a lot I feel like
every day I mean did you feel obligated
to you're like I got this vehicle no but
anytime I was bored I was always like
let me lower that in the water and go
out there I had like a little townhome
on the water that's pretty dumb so it
was cool and I could just lower it in
and go and whatever but yeah it was it
was always like oh I'm bored let me go
out here and go 60 on my jet ski in the
water and just rip it yeah right it was
always fun when you yeah when you're on
a jet ski Kim we're having this talk
when you're on a jet ski and you go full
throttle yeah and you're skimming over
the top of the surface and there's
nothing around you like one of the most
freeing feelings there can it definitely
is like a glass out there it's and then
I'd argue this being behind somebody and
like not dry
I doubt that ever happens to you but
doing that is also one of the most
frightening things because you have no
control I know that is scary holding on
to some idiot who's driving a jetski 50
miles per hour
one thing I used to do that was stupid
there's like these big tankers used to
come into the bay right you'd ride there
I like to ride there wakes man you think
it's fun until you get closer holy you
go holy [ __ ] this wakes like 30 feet
high like and you start to worry that's
where I did that one so who are you
taking this barnburner well I'm going to
take the Bucs at home on I'm putting $10
in the bucks I think they're gonna win
the football game I mean the Bucs
offense is still somewhat dangerous I
think they can protect Jameis Winston
the Falcons we've talked about how they
really don't do a lot on defense I just
think it favors the Bucs in this matchup
the Falcons offense I do think we'll be
able to move the ball in the Bucs - um I
don't know though I just I just feel
like the Bucs are gonna be a little bit
more motivated where the Falcons are
just like yeah we underperformed this
year we got an injured we should have
been better and we weren't and it's over
I read the quote from Dirk cutter yeah
it said Ryan Griffin will not only get
snaps yeah I've got a lot of snap and he
deserves it right and I flipped from
Tampa Bay to Atlanta and I will be
taking the Falcons at plus one at $50
yeah because 50 - I don't know I don't
know how many snaps Jameis is gonna get
yeah and I think when your quarterback
comes out and they're trying out people
that to me is a cue when everyone stops
caring as much I think the Falcons got a
rush last week they beat the crap out of
the Panthers their punter body slammed a
guy and got a lot of attention on social
media which i think is a rush right and
I think the Falcons in Dan Quinn he's
already put both coordinators on notice
and Tampa I'm sitting there going I have
no idea how I would sum up these teams
the Tampa Bay Bucs in 2018 I'd call it
the driverless car hmm no idea I don't
know who's at the wheel for the GM I
don't know who's at the wheel head coach
yeah I don't know who's at the wheel for
the quarterback right they got rid of
their DC I look at that team and I go
it's just going down the street yeah I
have no idea who's at the head of it no
it's it's hard to get a feel for who's
leading that free sometimes it went
straight like against the Cowboys like
look at that
you know like they could they could hang
in games and they could throw the ball
there's some talented pieces no idea
yeah Atlanta 2018 the Falcons the
crumbled corps mmm everything that that
team stood for got banged up yeah the
d-line the linebacker the safety the
offensive line the tenets of the defense
the cover 3 press bail fell apart the
offense of what it stood for came down
the very middle of that team it got
exposed for not having depth yes not
having depth of play calling not having
depth at positions not not getting good
you know exclusive rights free agents
and building your special teams the
entire Corps crumbled here's how I'd
summarize that I think that's a good way
to put it certainly I don't know one of
the weird things in the media too is to
me we're like I don't and this is not
this I'm gonna sound like a pylon I
think maybe I talked about this so if I
did stop me I just don't understand why
like this is what drives me crazy about
our business why Aaron Rodgers gets
criticized like this year towards the
end all he's not the same he's not doing
as well they're not winning but then and
he's being paid all this money and oh
god she's being overpaid buh buh buh but
then Matt Ryan who has Julio Jones and
Calvin rittany and Mohamed Sanu and
Tevin Coleman and his offensive line was
healthy he got a free pass because the
defensive players were hurt I just I'm
just not trying to be I have a theory
I'm a theory right when you get to play
some years with an offensive genius a
lot of the attention gets put on that so
right now it's before Kyle and it's
after Kyle yeah and so they're going oh
see this is an offensive coordinator
issue because that offensive coordinator
left and that often just great now Aaron
Rodgers has never had anybody with him
that's ever been called that Darrell
Bevell moved on and flamed out Joe
Philbin moved on and flamed out all of
the other offensive Minds haven't panned
out so I don't know that's just a theory
I have yeah a lot of its being thrown at
the feet of the OSI where yeah you're
right it is where I know I know and I
just it's just weird to me that's all
I'm saying I'm just food for thought
that's awesome all right next one
all right we're into the four o'clock
games to see the whole list of four
o'clock games Cleveland at Baltimore
right mark Andrews the tackle has come
out and are the the tight end yeah said
Baker's gonna try and mess it up for us
I'm talking about both quarterbacks he
said guys like Lamar and Baker they have
certain of things about them it's the it
factor to rookie quarterbacks going we
have seven rookie quarterbacks going
this week baltimore going for the AFC
North to make a left go look like a
genius to pick them to beat the Steelers
the Browns all they can do right now is
play spoiler but I don't know if there's
a hotter team in the NFL right now than
the Cleveland Browns Baltimore favored
by six at home Sims what do you think
well I think first real game first real
guesses is the first real game and I
think it's scary for the Ravens I really
do I think the Cleveland Browns really
match up with Baltimore I do I don't
think there's really one we're all over
both you've been all over Baltimore
these last five weeks I've been pretty
big they're big bet for like the little
you're right I've been pretty good with
Baltimore I'm gonna shut up and like
well no no I'm just saying I wasn't
trying to be a jerk I didn't think I'm
saying chef because I'm feeling you're
gonna make a big bet oh no I'm just I do
feel like I have a good feel for
Baltimore and who matches up well with
them and who doesn't break it down and I
would think Cleveland matches up well
with them um one the first thing I
always look at Baltimore is are they
gonna overpower people out front I don't
think they're gonna overpower Cleveland
on either side of the ball to where
they're just gonna go oh we're gonna win
this matchup and they're gonna have a
hard time and they're gonna have to do
things schematically to change their
game plan no I don't look at it that way
to when I go to Cleveland's offense of
course we've talked about their
offensive line and it's very good it's
one of the better units of their team
their run game and hey you know I don't
know other way to say this but
motherfucker's Baker Mayfield dangerous
when you got a run game because if it's
one-on-one Baker
like Mark Andrews is saying he's gonna
go oh it's one-on-one I'll just throw
the come back 20 yards BAM on the money
Oh 20 yards on the program on the money
right so he's not afraid to throw in the
tight man-to-man coverage because he
goes I can put it where I want to wear
that one guy all I got to do is worry
about that one guy getting the ball and
put it somewhere so he's gifted that way
and then the Browns defense Greg
Williams
this kind of week where he's going for
two still maybe be the head coach and
Friday kitchens is one to be the OC you
know I just think that they're gonna
have a game plan especially with
Baltimore's offenses you and I know it's
not great at passing the ball they'll be
able to do some different things to put
more in the stop the run game basket and
because of that I'm putting $10 on the
Brad's I'm going to pick the Ravens
22:17 okay um but yes I think this is
scary for Baltimore I would expect them
to win but I will not sit here and be
like like jaw dropped in shock if you
know we saw like we saw last year in
Baltimore in week 17 oh man with
Cincinnati yeah like some big play at
the end where Baker makes a great throw
and also then they kick a game-winning
field goal in Baltimore gets knocked out
I would not be shocked if that outlook
everything that that that I usually do
looking at how emotions are and stuff
makes sense they're coming off this huge
win over the Chargers but they're still
fighting for their lives this feels like
history repeating itself yeah five or
six weeks ago the Browns beat the crap
out of the Bengals and they were feeling
really good and their next game was at
Houston against a really good defense
and Baker gynae got shook up a little
bit they had a few fumbles in you know
Callaway ether a pick six Antonio
Callaway fumbled right in the end zone
yeah they try to come back but they got
beat up by a bit a big defense that was
amazing that cow remember that was the
Callaway had the long touchdown I got
called back and two plays later he's
gone four touchdowns and bumbles of the
one in China I think a dad carry
Cleveland's offense under Baker has been
really really good at home they don't
really score that much when they're on
the road other than that one Bengals
game so I actually have $50 on the
Ravens to cover this mainly because I
think Baltimore is a really tough team
at home I think that they're I think the
the Browns are gonna come out wanting to
play spoiler but as you said the Ravens
got spoiled last year yeah so even
though Lamar didn't play that
whole team is going this ain't happening
again right and I think they're just
gonna pound and pound and pound I think
they cover but I don't think it's big
that's why I'm only putting fifty
dollars yeah the 2018 Cleveland Browns
the Baker has arrived yeah that's that's
how always this is when it begins do you
know what bakers like to me I don't know
if you know this I know you're a big
basketball fan
he's Donovan Mitchell mm-hmm and what I
mean by that is there's certain shooting
guards in the NBA that when they go from
college where it's 35 seconds and
there's a lot of offense and people pack
the lane and all that stuff and then you
get to the NBA and it's more of an
isolation game and it's more about how
athletic are you we're gonna give you
space they're gonna call those fouls
you know it's you're not getting pressed
yeah it's learning how to play that new
type of game
I look at Baker and what you just said
he looks at the NFL and it's a game
that's more made for hit if it's an
isolation game it's a one-on-one game
it's a matchup games accurate the
answers the coach is telling a bakery
things senses the matchup right and
that's what he specializes in and that's
I don't know if that's a good comparison
no I think it's a it just feels like the
shooting guard that's like oh it's an
open game up here I I agree I think they
have the talent right yeah I have the
talent to do that they're gonna set me
up I'm never going to the line of
scrimmage going I'm not sure what to do
against this blitz you know and again
I'm not trying to say but your that's a
good good analogy I really liked it
actually because in college a lot of the
times you just go up your gutter system
and you're going I hope he called the
right protection right I didn't even
tell me what to do against this blitz I
hope the line picks them up or there's
that stuff that goes on yes the game has
been it's it's handmade for him you're
right 2018 Baltimore Ravens the found
identity ooh and what I mean by that is
the Ravens have been trying to pass the
ball with Joe Flacco for like the last
six years yeah
and really all they've wanted to do is
protect the ball pound you on offense
put together 12 to 15 play dries and
then when your offense finally gets to
go on the field they go there are seven
guys in between the weights of 250 and
330 pounds and when I look to the right
there's Terrell Suggs looking at me
going on
gonna get ya and they finally get to be
that identity yeah they finally get it
yep
never forget that in the peak of Joe
Flacco is supposed to be the guy there
were rumors that the team wanted to go
with to Rod Taylor sure never forget
that before to Rod Taylor who was the
quarterback from Ohio State Troy Smith
yes
people wanted Troy Smith the team has
been clamoring for this kind of
quarterback and they finally got it in
Lamar Jackson
yeah identity definitely and they have
an identity yep and he will only get
better as a quarterback - so that's it
worse it's scary for what they can be
down the road Chargers at Denver right
Chargers are favored by six and a half
I'm gonna give you this nugget before
you go yeah Phillip Rivers has lost four
in a row in Denver hmm
Sims where are you going okay hope this
is the big yeah bet you do homie um okay
Nikki you ready Oh baby $10 on the
charger okay but again the Chargers
playing for something we know that there
still can win the AFC West
I think the Chargers are gonna be
disappointed with the way they played
last week especially on the offensive
side of the ball shutdown they're gonna
be a little disappointed with the fact
that they lost the Broncos a few weeks
ago in a game that they should have won
the Broncos though at home even though
it's meaningless week 17 it's still
tough place to play they still have some
talented guys in their defense I know
guys like Bradley Roby aren't gonna be
out there and little things like that I
mean the Chargers I have confidence or
I'm picking the 127 217 it's just I
don't have the confidence to pick book
big-money on it - just go they're gonna
blow this team out this week you know
especially when they just might you know
there is the part of them I don't know
III just that's what I feel I don't know
the way to put it the Denver Broncos in
the last four times that they've beat
Phillip Rivers in Denver yeah
scored 24 27 27 35 right the Broncos
don't have a manual Sanders
the Broncos don't have Demaryius Thomas
the Broncos don't have Philip Lindsay
yeah I have been watching this Broncos
teen the last few weeks they're
incapable of scoring points the Chargers
are angry they have a lot to play for I
am putting $200 on the Chargers
[Music]
juncos d I just this one looks it I look
at it and I go chargers chart the 2018
Los Angeles chargers ride the rivers
yeah there's gonna be some crashes it's
gonna be bumpy you're gonna get to those
whitewater but I'll tell you what ride
the rivers is gonna be fun
ride the river 2018 Denver Broncos
Bagger Vance yeah as in bag events Thank
You van it's time to go yeah he's gone I
would think it's gone yes babe the big
class two years whatever Broncos have
been wasted years wasted yeah Bob
Miller's part of the squares been wasted
yeah it was a questionable hiring I mean
they hired a defensive coach who the
year he got hired the Hexen 29:29
defense and football's got him hired so
I don't understand that anyways Oakland
at kansai just chickened out there like
me I love when you chicken out I wanna
do it like that's a lock for me but it
probably should be a lot for you that I
feel good about I don't know what it is
about Denver's defense at home I just
chickened out there a little bit I'm
just having watched Denver constantly on
offense yes no tight ends are hurt like
he's got no weapons they traded away the
weapon and then the next week the other
one got hurt right Oakland the team that
beat the Chargers and brought me back to
even that's what I get betting on the
traders baby
I love Raiders and I've actually made a
lot of money on the Raiders of season
Raiders at Chiefs cheese are favored by
13 and a half yeah let's do this one
quick Chiefs are fighting for home-field
advantage
yeah Chiefs are fighting for home-field
advantage and coming off a two-game
losing streak right so that's like and
Patrick mahomes is playing for the NRA
Seahawks right so Pat and Mandy Reed
wants him to win the MVP I just know
that's me all right and that's the way
Andy Reed works
he wants his quarterbacks to be you know
he likes to be that guy that coaches the
quarterback who had especially a year
but I do think the Chiefs like you said
playing for something at home and then
trying to go into the playoffs on a
positive note a team that's you know
been one of the top teams in football
all year they blew a game you know at
home against the Chargers a few weeks
ago and then of course didn't play all
that great
against the Seahawks Sunday night so I
look at that and then I think added the
fact that you know the Raiders really
had their swan song last week I think
that's where it concerns me about the
Raiders right you know like you know I'm
seeing Gruden hi-fi the fans and that's
what I mean that's a little it's a
little they gave their brush under
lighting a blunt on the Christmas Eve
right everybody was celebrating the fact
that this might be the end of Oakland we
want to game all these type of things
okay so $1,450 on the Kansas City cheese
that place is going to go crazy they
have a chance to be the number one seed
Derek Carr does a good great pass
protection that's one thing that he
Kansas City can do is rush the passer so
I don't worry about their secondary and
this matchup as much as other games
because I do think that their pass
rusher will get there and hit home added
to the fact that they've lost two games
out of the fight that's 43° and Derek
horse just all says a me Lackey the
Chiefs okay 1450 smackeroos and there
goes your lead so that means that you're
betting 1450 of a possible 1600 on the
Chiefs which means that you have a total
of of course a hundred and fifty on the
rest of your game yes you know what
right I'll do you a favor I'll take a
hundred and fifty and I'm gonna put on
the Raider I like it
why man why cuz I can't think of a
comment right now so no I can't have
good I am of course afraid that all of
the emotion has left the Raiders yeah I
am banking on the Raiders hounding the
Chiefs with a running game that I think
has actually worked the last few weeks
it's been good pretty good this is a
Raiders team that has already proven to
themselves that they can score on this
Chiefs defense this is a Chiefs defense
that every time I watch is getting
destroyed by offenses 13 and a half
points is
a lot when you have a defense that can't
hold people under 24 do I believe that
cheese can put up a lot of points of
course I forgot that Derek Carr is not
that great in the cold yeah and I'm
gonna need it to not be that but it just
to mean little Adsit this is the one I
believe you put 1450 on a thirteen and a
half points yeah you're gonna be
nauseous it wasn't it didn't scare it
and the fact that I wasn't scare me you
have a legitimate chance to beat me I
need to do well on a lot of other bets
it's really gonna cry
I was really worried that you were gonna
be big on this game and I was gonna be
wasting all I was all bad I know this is
amazing it's the best Christmas gift you
ever gave I'll bet it you know what if
there's one team you know what last week
let me pull up them I've been there and
meanie ously we hold on team last read
on last week I bet on Oakland you bet on
Denver who covered that you did you're
right I did
the week before that you bet on Oakland
I bet on Cincinnati who covered that a
guy did two weeks in a row that I've
known Oakland three weeks ago
Pittsburgh Oakland you bet on Pittsburgh
I bet on Oakland what happened yes
Oakland been all over it the week before
that Kansas City Oakland we both went
Kansas City and from then on I said
never again Jon Gruden you grind your
way
20:18 Kansas City Jon's written they
played on Monday they got Tuesday off I
mean they literally just started game
planning yesterday they're like oh wait
we got a game this weekend we've been
celebrating with our Oakland fans still
2018 Oakland Raiders Gruden his grind
here are the grinding 2018 Kansas City
Chiefs year zero here zero here zero
yeah after this year if never the same
never the same same he's like the Holy
One is Hatcher Holmes was born in the
year 2018 the surrendering at year 0 0 0
after this the NFL will never be the
same yeah and before this it was the
word before Patrick gonna be BP in
Kansas City forever now B for patty
before patty that's that's right after
this years after patty I tell you my new
mahomes song
song just like Aaron Rodgers you need a
beat or is it a cappella no it's Aqaba
my homie my homie my homie wherever I go
he goes my homie my homie Patrick
mahomes I like him a lot
do you know that one you know that right
yeah we're curious my homie
why are you did you practice this I done
it before I'm gonna continue to do it as
we go through the playoffs my homie my
homie my homie wherever I go
will you do this you were my buddy right
yeah good you know the numbers kids
sister right kids sister kids sister
kids sister kids sister and me oh my
that's my homie he's gonna deliver this
week all right let's go gather your
dreams and your zero let's go to your
other homie
Kyle Shanahan the San Francisco 49ers at
Sean McVeigh and the LA Rams a rivalry
that is actually bitter and nobody talks
about it and it's really great because
they both want to be the smartest young
coach in the NFL that's right and the
Rams are favored by 10 you are putting
your $10 on the 49ers okay I do I mean
yeah I guess
the Rams not playing good football I
think the 49ers again you know this the
defense is better than people give it
credit for I think it's one of the more
underrated early units in all a football
what they do
also when you're not good at stopping
the run that always concerns me when you
have to play Kyle Shanahan because it's
just so much of his offense is built off
of that so yeah I'm picking the Rams to
win 28 to 23 and it's maybe it's more I
didn't have a great feel for it though
those 49ers would scare me in this
matchup they really would I wouldn't be
shocked to the 49ers when winning this
game 23 20 halfway through the fourth
quarter
I really wouldn't be I don't think
they're gonna fall asleep again I think
it was a lot like last year
Shanahan second year he's gonna want to
end on a good note
there's not been a lot of pauses the
deal was this year the hell he's gonna
gameplan the thing you talked about is
definitely very real nice they're
buddies and you know it just like
anything I want to beat your ass this
weekend so you don't win and he's
feeling the same way he's gonna I can
ruin McVeigh's chance to go Super Bowls
in a while
einar's they got a lot of guys that felt
like they were snubbed DeForest Buckner
all that stuff I want to prove that I
have $50 on the San Francisco 49ers plus
10 as well I just I don't know I know
girlies not playing and the Rams are a
team that I could see resting people
even though they shouldn't the 2018 Los
Angeles Rams the mcveigh way it's
official the whole team buys in I
mentioned the shop earlier Todd Gurley
talked about Sean McVeigh on that show
glowing right he's our age he's a genius
it's affirmative right now that's the
McVeigh way they got to figure it out I
have like that that show what I don't
know I don't know if you want me to go
there so I'm trying to hold my tongue
let's talk about it afterwards
Sanford the 2018 San Francisco 49ers
jimmies bad date like you're telling me
you didn't like the porn star no just
how about whatever the date was and
which his injury happened it was you
know it was you know what it was 20 1872
49ers was the letdown he leaned in in
that Chiefs game and he didn't need to I
got hurt and at that moment the season
was thrown away yeah and now we're left
with questions that Kyle's gonna have to
answer going into his final year right
he really is yeah because their defense
has kind of played pretty well the
running game is coming good but him and
Adam GaSe in a very similar situation
yeah and we got a hope Jimmy Jimmy comes
back and is ready to go exactly right
Chicago at Minnesota Minnesota favored
by four and a half at home Minnesota has
turned it around the last few weeks
Chicago is just marching a beat of their
drum beating people up Chicago might
rest people Minnesota got a win to get
in and then they're sort of favored by
four and a half what do we know about
the Bears they haven't said anything
about resting anybody has come out and
said that he wants to play all of his
starters unless it gets to a point where
they're winning by so much or the other
game is so immense or winning by so much
that maybe they'll pull out which is why
I'm rooting for the Niners too that's
why yeah it's really it's an interesting
psyche for this game for the Bears
you're really during during you know
like a where you can go two ways you go
all in and say we're gonna win we don't
want to play this team for a third
for third time again the next week and
get them done with and we'd rather face
face the Eagles a new fresh team
whatever it may be but like I said you
lose the chance there if you do lose
your team psyches gonna lose a little
bit they're gonna go damn we tried to
win today and now they're coming to town
again I mean we showed us tough at home
exactly right so there's that aspect and
then there's the aspect of oh okay yeah
we'll just you know fold the tents and
take the week off I don't see it either
but I don't see how they're gonna do
what they're saying they're gonna do
like oh we're gonna if we're blowing
them out we'll take it off I mean so I
mean what if they look up in the third
quarter and the Rams are up by ten are
they gonna quit no they're gonna keep
going
okay so tens amount what's the number
that they're gonna go okay twenty-one
right alright so that is just weird all
together you're put on $10 on the Bears
okay I'm putting them on the Bears
I think the Bears are gonna go for the
kill this weekend and I don't think the
Vikings match up well with the Bears I
mean of course it scares me that we're
in Minnesota I understand that I have
been there - yeah but that philosophy
ain't tried true enough yet to mess with
this bears defense I think and I think
Duff time moving the ball of them the
the Bears to me are a lot like the the
Bears at four and a half are a lot like
the Cowboys at +6 they're too good to be
more than three point underdogs yeah
it's a divisional game I don't see the
Vikings winning like that I have $50 on
the Chicago Bears as well I just think
that I'm really so bears are so high EEP
the Bears are so deep that even if like
some of those guys come out like they
can still go there and beat him up yeah
I still believe that and the Vikings are
not like the Vikings played really well
against Miami and against who Detroit
Detroit okay here's a whole new team
yeah here the bear another level
oh the 2018 Chicago Bears Mac in the
monsters hmm it's been beautiful it has
been beautiful ever since he got traded
he's lived up to the billing and
exceeded it Chicago is play is built
like a team is built the way a Chicago
Bears team should be built right and
it's exciting they made all the right
moves all the right man it's awesome
Ryan pace GM of the year yeah I mean I
really believe a new era I mean it
really is special 2018 Minnesota Vikings
I'm giving our
all she's got captain hmm Captain Kirk
they ain't got enough yeah
they ain't got enough and everyone's
putting it on the captain right and
that's how I look at it yeah I just
can't dude captain you just can't do it
don't have the power it's really good
scouts I know thank you
Cincinnati at Pittsburg it's a wait who
did you pick there I picked $50 on the
Bears you dollars on the Bears do you
think they're gonna win
I'm yes why no you're hiring them too I
know you are I mean you want my goggles
in my gut tells me that Minnesota wins
by like two you think they're gonna win
by two I know I'm fascinated by this
game it really annoys me that my
preseason pick for the NFC East was that
the Cowboys win the division and the
Eagles miss out at nine and seven and
it's now they know they're gonna miss
out at nine and seven like yeah I hate
that that prediction was on yeah well it
could be right if you couldn't do the
Cowboys when the East and they get in on
nine and seven so that could be right
yeah I hope so yeah
um there's a chance I I do not think the
Bears are gonna sleep through this I
hope not Cincinnati at Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh favored by 14 and a half yeah
Pittsburgh pissed off you know
Pittsburgh you everybody's listen to me
knows anything about me I'm a believer
in Pittsburgh I think they're one of the
best teams in football unfortunately I
mean they just find ways to mess games
up that's part of their DNA you know the
Bengals really nothing to play for
there's been a few things that have been
positive lately I will say that Joe
Mixon since he's been back since injured
he has looked like one of the better
running backs in football I think he's
been phenomenal Driscoll has had moments
of being he's been better than what I
thought he would I'll say that much but
I think Pittsburgh's too motivated here
they put them away
I'm putting $10 on the Steelers because
I'm scared the Steelers will somehow
screw up at some point in this game and
make it a little closer than what it may
be like this was the game I looked at
was like like the Steelers are gonna
pull away in this and at some point it's
gonna be like 35 to 13 but then I just
thought well no i-i've thought that for
the last six weeks in a row with the
Steelers they're gonna win this game or
do this and they always have those two
or three plays where I go what and
that's why I don't trust it but I think
they went 28:13 I am putting $50 in the
Bengals plus four and a half
under Big Ben the Steelers have been
favourites of 14 and a half or more
three times and they have never covered
the spread fourteen and a half is a
monster line yeah and the Bengals are
not that good but guess what they
somehow came back last week in Cleveland
and only lost by 814 a half is a lot
yeah I'm going $50 in the Bengals well
the 2018 Cincinnati Bengals done with
Dalton hmm that's how it feels to double
D that it feels like the end of an era
that you know it's time to answer
questions yeah I I agree that's how it
feels to me the 2018 Pittsburgh Steelers
the missing pieces
hmm where would they be with levy on
where would they be with Ryan shazier if
both of those guys were playing this
year they could be 14 into that's how I
feel about that team yeah is that here
we are going why are they messing up why
is it not happening because arguably
their two best players on both sides of
the ball didn't play this year sure
like we forget that those two guys
missed and yet they're still right in
the hunt as maybe the best team in the
NFL it's crazy they're not it's crazy
they're not gonna get to the playoffs at
least in my eyes just I'm just saying
that from somebody who evaluates
football like I've said alas you yes
they're just it's good they've really
blown it I mean this year and last year
they could have won the Super Bowl last
year they could have stood toe-to-toe
with your Eagles and I do believe that
they could have came out in the AFC they
still can if they somehow got in I'm not
expecting them to get in but yeah I mean
it's just um
that Chargers loss charges loss will be
will haunt them forever
Ben's sipping pina coladas in the second
half because he oh the x-rays that's I
mean they couldn't Rock right those
those were those were horrible losses
yeah horrible I mean even the Saints
game was horrible last week but we can
at least swallow that because we know
the Saints are really good man yeah
Arizona at Seattle Seattle favored by 13
and a half yeah I mean Arizona on the
road what am I gonna say to their other
than I don't have a lot of faith in
their
offense in general I mean this the
Seahawks don't have really anything to
play for really I guess they seeding is
important I'd Pete Carroll I read some
of his comments earlier this week he's
not they're playing fair play are
playing he doesn't want to do that he's
gonna go into the playoffs a full steam
ahead and at home against the Cardinals
I think it's only a matter of time be
kind of it before they overwhelm them
really yes and you know the the Seahawks
I guess the big thing is they're playing
to make sure they go play Dallas and not
have to go place your cog right because
if they if they lost some Minnesota wins
that will get switched right you don't
then they'll have to go to Chicago and I
don't think that's their cup of $10 on
the CEO and dollars on the Seahawks this
is the only game with a monster spread
in which I'm taking the favorite and I'm
putting a hundred and fifty dollars on
the Seahawks - thirteen and a half the
Seahawks at home against NFC West
Arizona I know that Arizona has given
them some problems in the past yeah
this is an Arizona offensive line that
can't block anybody this is a
quarterback that's mistake-prone this is
a quarterback that's never played in
Seattle this is a Seattle team that Doug
Baldwin gets to the podium after the
last game where they beat the chase
Chiefs and go were savages the Seahawks
and Pete Carroll want to make a run they
are a team that this is their last
chance they get to play at home final
home game of the season I think they're
gonna beat the everliving crap out of
the Arizona Cardinals
I think it's gonna be a bloodbath I
really believe that it's an amazing
matchup for the Seahawks the Seahawks
getting a low average quarterback at
home he's like yeah it's tough it's the
danger not happened the 2018 Arizona
Cardinals the rose and one walks through
the desert just like Moses he's going
through the desert for 40 years right
he's got to learn what it's like to get
punched in the mouth every play what
it's like to throw picks it's been a
very tough first year with a wunderlist
coach he's being led by Steve Wilkes
where who knows where he's going the
2018 Seahawks
the new legion is the old legion oh you
thought it's been the defense all along
it's been Pete Carroll it's been Russell
Wilson it's been Bobby Wagner and it's
been good special teams yeah I know that
they've had good pieces but really Bobby
Wagner in the middle with Russell Wilson
and Pete Carroll is good enough to get
it done and back to the running game
which got him there to speak to your old
legion right art the new legion is the
old lead yeah um back to basics
Philadelphia at Washington Philadelphia
playing for their playoff lives favored
by seven in Washington yeah I mean of
course I'm taking the Eagles I'm putting
$10 in the Eagles let's just start it
off right there yeah I have a hard time
[Music]
you know the Redskins do match up okay
with the Philadelphia Eagles there's
certain matchups there that I look at
and go okay they're in a decent spot
there the way they play defense I do
think can give your offense problems um
you know their offense can give your
defense problems because you know even
with some of their injuries and again
this is where you gotta give Jay Gruden
credit you gotta give Bill Callahan
their old line credit yeah they find
ways to protect and run the ball every
week I mean it's amazing but Adrian
Peterson's doing as well
I clearly expect your Eagles to kind of
control the football game I just don't
think it's gonna be like a super blowout
I don't see it that way I kind of see it
as like a 7 nothing it's 10 nothing it's
10 3 then it maybe it's 13 3 13 6 and
then 16 16 something like that right and
then maybe a touchdown maybe to finally
go whatever and that's why I picked the
Eagles the 123 to 9 that's how I'm
picking the game I kind of see it
unfolding that way but $10 on the Eagles
nonetheless I believe that Washington is
one of those teams that seemingly always
is annoying to the Eagles yes even the
season opener last year where the Eagles
won by 14 points right it was only
because Fletcher Cox returned that
fumble for a touchdown that's right and
they had a few deep passes that went
Washington is always annoying to the
Eagles that last year or two years ago
that was
the Eagles win this game but I believe
that seven is too much I am putting $50
on Washington I believe the Eagles win
this game by three or four okay the 2018
Philadelphia Eagles waiting on Wentz hmm
everything the beginning of the year
we're waiting on Wentz he comes back hey
we're not that good but it's okay
because we're waiting on whens to make
the place right and then they finally
don't wait on Wentz and here's falls
yeah and they're playing great such an
inch like yeah it's amazing it's really
like if the Eagles get in the playoffs
anything can happen
they they to me are the bigger wild
cards of the Vikings because there's
just something indescribable about them
yeah I would have belief they have
believed yeah they have a little more
battle-tested I mean they know yes
you're right that they can do this and
they did it last year with Nick Foles I
think there's there's something to that
yeah something to it right the 2018
Washington team Dan Snyder is the
problem huh one year after not even a
year after hiring three new people in
his front office to change the business
aspect he fires them I don't know how
this is not from your words this is mine
that Bruce Allen is still operating this
team the lack of depth on this roster
the complete turnover year to year the
miss handling of the quarterback
situation the contract Alex Smith that
we now are gonna have to pay through
this injury the cutting of DJ swear
injure the the everything on this team
is a mess
and it all goes to Dan Snyder and I
believe that he is enabling Bruce Allen
and that it is the it is the canary in
the coalmine - what is wrong with this
franchise there their stadium is an
issue it is out of date and it's only
been existence for 21 years so nothing
can survive that man's ownership that's
that team yeah it's it's a shame
I'd like to you love the franchise I do
you've always loved wash I would like to
see them relevant I think that football
is better when they are
but yeah they're all over the place
front office stadium they say it players
on the field dan Snyder is that yeah I
agree with that I think it's hard to
deny that month a Sunday Night Football
whoa
playing to get in to the playoffs yeah
what an environment this will be yeah
I'm happy the games in Tennessee because
I think if the game was in India be a
blowout Marcus Mariota has a stinger in
his shoulder yep
India's favored by three and a half in
Tennessee you put in ten dollars on Indy
I'm putting ten dollars on it yes I am I
am yeah listen the Colts the Colts are
the better team to me I think that's the
the simplest way I can put it their
defense is sound even though it's not
overwhelming there's there's depth
there's always fresh bodies they very
rarely make mistakes on that side of the
ball they just got humbled in a close
one to the Giants exactly right and you
know the Tennessee offense
yeah the running games in better we know
that I get you it's the passing game
that I think scares me just on a
consistency basis I mean what's you know
what's Mario know went out that team
couldn't do anything right it's just I
don't know what to say there and I don't
think the Colts even though they're not
the greatest in the back end they're
just not the type of team that I look at
is gonna go oh man they're gonna get
tortured by this Tennessee Titans
offense this Tennessee Titans offense
they're passing attack I would argue is
not as good as the Giants that the Colts
faced last week I mean the Giants at
least a tenement Ingram is sterling
Shepard and some guys out there I
thought you I actually threw the ball
about as good as he's thrown all year
yeah it was but I look at that and then
I go to the Colts right and and listen
I'm not gonna like sugarcoat things I'm
rooting against the Titans in this I
don't want the Titans in the playoffs
you and me both I'm putting a hundred
and fifty on the Indianapolis con 150 on
the Colts
yeah I hear you there the Colts at least
Mariota is banged up Mariota is banged
up
they've never beat Andrew Luck for one
he's undefeated against the Tennessee
Titans and the Tennessee Titans have two
elite things on their roster and I would
say the Titan I mean the Indianapolis
Colts have two elite things on their
roster where I would argue the Titans
don't have one thing a lead on their
roster they have a lot of good don't get
me wrong there's a lot of solid
and he's a good player but the Colts
have arguably the best offensive line in
the sport it's an elite offensive line
and then they have an elite quarterback
and those two things there and these
type of situations I just go man an
elite quarterback with a lot of time to
throw and not the greatest pass rusher
in the world and a sound defense to back
it up yeah I'm going with that team I
think they win 24 213 I'm 24 14 Colts
these are the only ones I didn't come up
with ahead of time the 2018 Indianapolis
Colts oh I mean something about like the
fast rebuild they're on the fast track
fast track I feel like the 2018
Indianapolis Colts season is here come
the 2019 Indiana yes right something
like that I mean it's it's been one of
the quicker rebuild I would say this as
disappointing as last year was not
getting Andrew Luck back when we kind of
thought each week maybe he'd come back
right this year has been that enjoyable
to have him back with Leonard on the
defense and the the improved play of
Marga's hunt the offensive line the the
birth of people like naheem hines tea by
hilton playing Eric Ebron resurgence Mac
it's just been a joy to watch the 2018
Tennessee Titans they're good at home
like when they beat the Patriots when
they beat the Eagles they have had some
amazing wins at home yeah beat the crap
out of the Jaguars at home they've
really been special I also think that
2018 Tennessee Titans rables not there
yet
no I think that there has been a number
of times in which his decision-making
has directly led and then also you know
it's it's tough to know if Marcus
Mariota can be healthy yeah they're like
yeah I mean I hear you I think that's
kind of the way I would look at them and
just so like they're close but not there
yet
missing a piece or two where they they
have no difference makers I think that's
really the big thing to me there's no
big difference maker or a unit that is
Howard's and dreams hands might be
certainly my you know what I realized
about a Dori Jackson watching him the
other night yeah he's he's what you
worried Denzel
word would be yeah right he's always in
the guys pocket never but he never makes
a play the amount of times that he is
stride for stride with a receiver and it
never turns and puts his hands up is
incredible it is frustrating
yeah but Denzel Ward has more ball
skills yeah and a Dory is just he's the
athlete that doesn't have the ball
skills yeah that's crazy because he does
have good ball skills too I mean he can
catch the ball phenomenal yeah right
when he plays DB it doesn't show through
all the time alright so the difference
is between you and I you are betting on
the Giants minus six I am betting on the
Cowboys plus six like it you are betting
on Tampa minus one I am betting on
Atlanta plus one like it you are betting
on the Browns plus six I am betting on
the Ravens minus six love it you are
betting on the Chiefs minus thirteen and
a half I am betting on the Raiders plus
thirteen and a half and there is a $1600
swing in that game that game incredible
you are betting on the Steelers minus 14
and a half I am betting on the Bengals
plus 14 and a half you are betting on
the Eagles minus 7i and mushing it with
the Washington team plus seven I have
five teams circled for my left collogues
yeah help me narrow it down to four okay
number one and a thousand percent going
in the Saints minus nine I've told you
I'm very convinced I love it number two
the Chargers minus six and a half I can
be convinced otherwise number three the
Niners plus ten gotcha number four the
Seahawks minus thirteen and a half
definitely like that - number five the
Colts - three and a half that one's a
little scary to me yep and you're 49 I
think I'd like you're 49 there's no one
better than the Colts one so the
original four that I had is the four
that I'm starring right now Saints -
nine Chargers - six and a half
Niners plus ten Seahawks - thirteen and
a half yeah I think that's pretty good
it's a killer to go with all the big
ones but the true thing is is I hope the
Jets can stay within thirteen and a half
I hope the Raiders can stay within 13
and a half and I hope that the Bengals
can stay within 14 and a half but the
Niners are the one team that I go oh no
they're uh they're a good team I still
believe I would be shocked if they got
blown out I would I don't expect them to
win but I do think they'll keep it close
are you ready to do guaranteed to lose
you know yeah I got to figure out there
are so many teams that are guaranteed to
lose this week I don't even know where
to pick actually I'm like a little
flustered here going through this I have
her so I am one of the groomsmen for one
of my good friends wedding yes and on
Sunday is the rehearsal dinner and I'm
giving a speech right all of these games
are gonna be going on oh my gosh that's
horrible
I'm just gonna be watching on my phone
you just have to learn to say no no I'm
a groomsman no it's my guy job I got a
job if he was you're such a good friend
he would have not scheduled his wedding
during football season and know what
your job was really funny oh sorry he is
a college soccer coach I used to be a
professional women's soccer coach yeah
and he missed all of our friends
weddings because he had games now he's
planning it on the deciding Sunday of
all of NFL season geez what a disaster
all right are you ready I have six teams
it's really hard to figure out what do
you want to do six or do you want to go
five all this season you're 60 and 20 I
am 60 in 27 batting 75% officially huh I
mean I might as well go six this week
who cares six teams guaranteed to lose
and Nikki G where are we going
oh it's Happy New Year some of the teams
and knock at home I have no idea which
one you're going to first but I'm
assuming it's your old home
Oh my old home I'm going to Jacksonville
Happy New Year Jacksonville Blake
bortles of starting and you will lose
once again Happy New Year sorry
Jacksonville Texans are playing for your
New Year's resolution is to move on from
Blake bortles the next one Oh
our good friend Sammy boy Sammy you were
so cute as Santa Claus but sorry you're
going up to see Tommy Boy
Happy New England year because it's
always there you're in the AFC's you
will lose to them they are still playing
for something and they want to play
better sorry Jets you LOSC lose lose
lose lose all right next one up a new
year's resolution for resolution
what's John Elway's New Year's
resolution to find a new head coach yeah
oh hello yes Broncos you're gonna lose
it's the Los Angeles chargers and make
still can get a first round bye
and Broncos that's done it's over see
you next year you're getting a new head
coach all right we know this guy really
well the New Year's resolution could be
to get a haircut but he won't say well
get one Chucky doesn't get haircuts okay
but Chucky is going to lose against the
Kansas City Chiefs you know why you know
why I feel this because my mom Dirty
Diana said so don't call my mom dirty
how dare you said I didn't mean to okay
you better apologize
next team guaranteed to loose oh it is a
team that has had New Year's resolutions
for 20 years and has never follow them
how can I pick the Cincinnati Bengals to
beat the big mad mean Pittsburgh
Steelers sorry Cincinnati you lose I'm
definitely going 5a no this week I feel
really good but will you go six no cuz
your final guaranteed to lose oh and you
said the Rosen one was walking through
the desert well he'll he'll need some
water in this one because he is gonna
lose the Seattle up in Seattle Seattle
is tough to beat you can't Seattle out
Seattle see
in Seattle and they're not going to do
that sorry I'm going six and oh I always
want to keep going and see where I might
lose because the Redskins they could
have made this list seventeen that's a
guarantee
okay who else could it almost make this
list hey bucks I think they could
probably be asleep calm down did I pick
the Panthers you did not they definitely
can make it 17 yeah they definitely
could was that 18 that's seven you're
right and that's where all 17 guaranteed
to lose that was our worst one of the
year on New Year's Josh's idea for the
song just go seriously so the 7 teams
guaranteed to lose are the Jaguars the
Jets the Panthers the bucket I don't
remember I did the Jags the Jets the
Browns the Raiders the Bengals I did the
Cardinals and the Redskins and then I
threw in the Panthers in there mmm for
eight all right that's eight teams 18
guarantee like nobody goes out in the
new year like me baby seriously um it
this is our this is our final round of
the regular season
yeah it's been a pleasure as always
always is we are gonna continue this
into the postseason yes we are we're
I'll still be 16 less I'm winning at the
end of the week never quitting but I
just want I wanted to say this is that
this is the time of the year where Sims
gets really good it is not going to be
about the plus 14 and a half's it's
about the plus sixes of the Browns this
is the reason you did well I think last
week with Pittsburgh and New Orleans and
with Baltimore and chargers yeah
everyone is fine at picking up and
flipping a coin but you're really good
at the teams that matter at the end of
the year Thanks so I'm gonna try and
steal a lot of your picks to hold on to
yet another champion okay good
cuz I can go out having beaten you this
many years in a row geez I'll hold it
over your head for the road out - what's
up where you going out - you said you're
going out yeah we're going out
Oh God forceps these at home venture
could say
evening I'm an Argentine hola and the
lef koe man says holla holla holla
enjoy your games everybody I hope your
team gets in the playoffs except if
you're a Minnesota family there's gonna
be honest yeah that's good it's about
time you started rooting for your team
you're only biased if you don't show
your bias
well aren't you guys later peace out
you